let me tell you right off that I did not
invent this field we've detected
gravitational waves from thus crashing
of two black holes into each other this
is the beginning of a whole new way of
studying the universe
it's like Galileo using the telescope
for the first time what is a
gravitational wave
it's an excitation of space and time
together nobody really believed that you
could ever detect them because the size
of the effect is so small I came to
conclusion that if you made this
kilometer scale you could probably get
these extremely precise measurements I
said holy mackerel yard the best of a
lengthy array
thank Google regulations
[Music]
you